[Música]
[Aplausos]
cada año escuchamos y leemos las cifras
alarmantes del cambio climático que
tantas toneladas de dióxido de carbono
fueron emitidas que cuántos grados de
temperatura aumentaremos este año e
incluso hectáreas devastadas por
incendios forestales
parecieran qué noticia tras noticia todo
se volviera más caótico hasta el punto
de pensar si realmente a alguien se
encuentra haciendo algo para revertir o
tan solo para disminuir los efectos del
cambio climático pues la realidad es que
mientras hablamos de esto se llevan a
cabo toda una serie de esfuerzos
acelerados alrededor de todo el mono por
lograr tecnologías cada vez más
sustentables que hagan la diferencia e
impacten a millones de personas
entonces quién es o qué cosa se nos
viene a la mente cuando hablamos de
tecnologías sustentables los ayudará un
poco qué tal si hablamos de coches
eléctricos quién lidera
-claro está- eeuu o alemania
si hablamos de energía renovable de
dónde vienen los paneles solares
adores esta china europa eeuu incluso
proyectos de ciudades completamente
verdes están de nuevo países de europa
japón medio oriente y eeuu y si te
detienes a pensar un poco te preguntas
qué está ocurriendo
acaso en américa latina nadie hace nada
por esta causa de entrada no tiene que
ver con que no existan las tecnologías o
proyectos que pueden ser igual o más
relevantes que la de los países llamados
primermundistas porque en la región
existe la capacidad preparación y
convicción de jóvenes que están
cambiando el planeta pero muchas veces
se tiende a menospreciar la tecnología
desarrollada en casa y preferir la del
extranjero a este efecto se le conoce
como senos centrismo tecnológico donde
se considera que los productos
nacionales tienen una calidad inferior
en comparación con los productos del
extranjero donde por muchos años
décadas se nos ha vendido esta idea que
cualquier cosa que provenga del exterior
tiene que ser mejor pero realmente lo es
pues consecuencia del bombardeo
mediático de la cultura extranjera donde
poco a poco nos hemos apropiado de las
costumbres de las creencias incluso
desarrollos tecnológicos que aparecen en
películas series o en internet para
ejemplificar esto me gustaría hacer un
ejercicio rápido con ustedes piensen en
al menos dos productos tecnológicos que
tengan en casa y sean de una marca
latinoamericana están listos corre
tiempo
es complicado no pero ahora hagamos lo
más interesante que pasa cuando
combinamos lo tecnológico con lo
sustentable en qué personaje o líder
pensamos cuando hablamos de la lucha
contra el cambio climático en la región
puede tornarse aún más complejo pero si
echamos un poco de memoria a finales de
los 90 surgió un premio latinoamericano
del nobel mario molina el científico
pionero que sentó las bases del
adelgazamiento de la capa de ozono y dio
paso a que la humanidad se planteara el
daño que estaba causando y sobre todo
las consecuencias que tendrían para el
futuro en pocas palabras el inicio de la
preocupación por el cambio climático y
claro la aparición de las fotos del
osito polar en el hielo derritiéndose
entonces cuando empezamos a unir todas
las piezas entre las preferencias
tecnológicas del extranjero acerca de la
sustentabilidad la lucha por el cambio
climático y lo que estamos haciendo en
latinoamérica te surge un sentimiento de
querer hacer más y sobre todo cambiar al
mundo levantando la mano desde nuestras
trincheras estas preguntas e ideas
fueron las que rebotaban estaban en
mente ya desde hace varios años
por ello en el 2018 por parte de un
esfuerzo por demostrar que la ciencia es
uno de los pilares para mitigar al
cambio climático y que también puede ser
cool en los negocios confunde la start o
biotecnológica en méjico donde
encontramos una manera innovadora de
transformar los edificios en los
pulmones de la ciudad y cuando hablamos
de pulmones de la ciudad seguro que se
les viene a la mente lo clásico árboles
bosques parques nacionales pero no esta
innovación proviene de las microalgas
los cuales son unos pequeños
microorganismos que llegamos a encontrar
en casi cualquier charco de agua los
cuales otorgan una coloración verde y
ayudan a limpiar el aire como los mismos
árboles incluso puede que tú no lo sepas
pero este pequeño organismo fue uno de
los causantes de que hace millones de
años la tierra se llenará de oxígeno y
que hoy en día aporten más del 50% del
aire que respiramos año
así fue que aprovechando las microalgas
y combinando la con nanotecnología
creamos los bio paneles solares es un
sistema que ayuda a limpiar el aire
genera energía y regula la temperatura
de los edificios
otorgando un diseño vanguardista que
permite aprovechar las fachadas y
generar mayores ahorros energéticos
así es que si nos ponemos en un contexto
de todos estos beneficios de los bio
paneles digamos que los ponemos en una
fachada de un edificio de 30 pisos
ahorraríamos una tercera parte de la
energía necesaria y limpiaremos la misma
cantidad de dióxido de carbono que
100.000 árboles maduros lo cual es igual
a un pequeño bosque de 100 hectáreas en
la ciudad de esta manera es que esta
tecnología ayudará a acelerar la
transición hacia la ciudad de
sustentables combinando naturaleza y
tecnología en un mismo sistema y
revalorizando la ciudad mediante un
monitoreo inteligente de datos
aquí lo curioso de esta experiencia ha
sido el cómo se ha logrado que esta
tecnología
latinoamericana en desarrollo tenga un
mayor impacto afuera que incluso dentro
de la región pues está generando un gran
interés en más de las 10 economías con
mayor desarrollo del mundo catalogándola
como una de las tecnologías sustentables
más innovadoras de latinoamérica y del
mundo por organismos como el lema y el
g20 y la revista foros entre otros
este hecho ejemplifica perfectamente un
proceso que realizamos sin siquiera
saber una innovación inversa es decir
creamos una solución desde un país
latinoamericano con el objetivo de
llegar a países con gran desarrollo
económico y así tener un impacto
focalizado pero con mayor alcance volar
en lugar de dejar que ellos nos vendan
su tecnología nosotros alcanzaremos un
mercado como uno de los principales
objetivos
pero si lo analizamos desde otro punto
de vista de urgencia para el cambio
climático puede ser la mejor opción pues
al colocar estos pulmones en las
principales capitales del mundo
ayudaremos a reducir las zonas que
contaminan más nuestro planeta
mejoraremos la calidad de millones de
personas y reduciremos un sesgo
internacional de que tecnologías de este
tipo no se pueden desarrollar en zonas
como la nuestra como en latinoamérica
atrayendo entonces mayor inversión un
desarrollo de la zona y mejoras de
oportunidades para una mejor calidad de
vida sin embargo la cuenta regresiva por
salvar al planeta está avanzando y en
verdad no se detiene cada segundo que
pasa nuestro planeta muere lentamente si
en los últimos años hemos logrado
derribar las fronteras físicas con la
era digital si hemos iniciado una
revolución por un mundo más justo e
inclusivo ahora es momento que sin
pensarlo construyamos juntos un futuro
más sostenible donde inversionistas
gobierno y sociedad
aceleren las tecnologías sustentables
que mitigarán al cambio climático
por ello es muy importante que hoy en
día empecemos a cambiar la manera de
pensar e impulsar proyectos tecnológicos
de la región porque yo sé muy bien que
cambiarán la vida de millones de
generaciones porque capacidad y
tecnología existen las hay las he visto
en persona y todos estos proyectos están
triunfando en el exterior la calidad de
una tecnología no se define por su
procedencia sino por la cantidad de
vidas que cambian promovamos de una
latinoamérica para el mundo y dejemos de
lado los estereotipos de los países en
vías de desarrollo
[Música]